hey youtubers is Charlie happy Superbowl
Sunday so we're gonna be getting a whole
bunch of stuff today but I wanted to
start with Deadpool and Ryan Reynolds
because he just said that he wants to
play Deadpool for the rest of time so
what does that mean most of you have
probably learned to take what Hollywood
actors say with a grain of salt but all
this means is that they're definitely
going to be working on a sequel Deadpool
is tracking for big box office it was a
relatively cheap movie to make
as far as big superhero movies go think
about x-men apocalypse they probably
spent twice maybe three times as much
making that movie in marketing in it
people are so crazy to see Deadpool that
Fox is actually spending more marketing
the movie than they spent to make it
that's how excited they are about it and
usually that's a pretty good sign that
they're gonna greenlight a sequel what
would that sequel be well the first
logical sequel would be Deadpool and
cable the first time Deadpool met cable
was the first time Deadpool appeared in
the comics during New Mutants number 98
Deadpool was hired to kill cable so
logically they would do a version of
that in the comics obviously they've had
a long relationship together haven't
always been at each other's throats so
the first time they appear on camera
together they would probably fight a
little then eventually they'd start
working together so even if they decided
to a Deadpool vs. Wolverine movie first
they can still include Easter eggs for
the first time Deadpool was hired to
kill cable before the story takes
whatever direction they want the movie
to take it's like Batman vs Superman
they're gonna fight each other at first
then they're gonna be friends and form
the Justice League it's kind of the same
thing with Deadpool on cable and
Deadpool and Wolverine although when
cable and Wolverine are forced to work
with Deadpool it's always bug reginal II
they always hate the out of him
it's just the guy that won't shut up the
Bugs Bunny character which a lot of
people are quoting in the movie there
have been advanced screening so people
are starting to review it of course
everybody loves it that's to be expected
it's gonna be a lot of fun but the other
key issue that you guys need to check
out if you haven't read it in a while it
might be on Marvel unlimited is
Wolverine number 88 from volume 2 that's
the first time Deadpool met Wolverine
the title of that story total Bugs Bunny
it's deaded a Deadpool folks they meet
because Wolverine goes to check on his
friend who's living with copycat
Deadpool's
ex-girlfriend he finds the Deadpool came
back to try and get copycat
that ended up trashing her place so
Wolverine gets pissed they fight and he
gets even more pissed when he finds he
can't wound Deadpool because of his
healing factor so like a Bugs Bunny
title implies it's a total Looney Tunes
story with Elmer Fudd Wolverine trying
to kill Bugs Bunny Deadpool I love the
idea of Elmer Fudd Wolverine
they're just so beautiful Hugh Jackman
would have so much fun a lot of you
might have noticed that he and Ryan
Reynolds are really good friends they've
been taking pictures together
I think Fox is really happy about that I
don't know necessarily the Deadpool vs.
Wolverine would be the next Deadpool
movie but it's totally possible it
depends on how much longer Hugh Jackman
wants to be Wolverine now he could
change his mind - like I said you learn
to take what Hollywood actors say with a
grain of salt Robert Downey jr.
originally was going to quit being Iron
Man at a certain point he's like okay
you know I'm a little too old for this
so I'm gonna pass the mantle on to the
next actor that Marvel wants to cast but
why do actors like that decide to stick
around mostly because the studio treats
them really well the fans loved it in
the movies are successful if the movies
tanked they probably like okay nobody
wants to see me do this again so I'll
move on so I think that Ryan Reynolds
seeing how crazy people are going for
Deadpool has really jazzed him up
seriously a lot of the love that you
guys are feeding him is repairing the
damage that Green Lantern did even
though actors get paid millions and
millions of dollars they still take it
really personally when people hate
characters that they play big big
characters there's a story Chris
Hardwick told about George Clooney at
Comic Con one year it was many many
years after George Clooney had been
Batman but Chris Hardwick said that he
made a little joke about Batman Batna
poles and George Clooney was like look
dude I just want to say I'm sorry I get
it that movie was terrible I just want
to apologize for ruining that character
obviously it's not all his fault that
Batman movie was terrible but it just
reminds you that even really powerful
really rich actors take it really
personally when people hate the stuff
that they do so on the flip side of that
I feel like this Deadpool experience has
made Ryan Reynolds feel like he's 15 and
just had sex for the first time again so
it's just like hell yeah I want to do
this again and the reason I'm talking
about Wolverine and cable so much for
the sequel is just because the people
associated with the film the director
the producers the actors have been
mostly talking about those characters
cable was one of the first people they
mentioned because
Miller was like I feel like people would
assassinate me if I didn't put Cable in
the sequel and then everyone was like
wait a minute you said sequel does that
mean that you're actually doing a sequel
then Ryan Reynolds is like hey yeah I
totally want to play deadpool forever so
it's like okay yeah we're probably gonna
see cable so I'm wondering if cable is
gonna be in one of the post-credits
scenes now in all the advanced
screenings that they did they actually
kept some of the scenes out so there are
a couple of new post-credit scenes so
whatever those are we won't see them
till the movie drops next week so I'm
thinking of the two post-credit scenes
one is Deadpool specific it's going to
be like cable or something like that and
the other is x-men specific because this
is part of the x-men universe so we'll
probably get a funny Deadpool
post-credit scene where he breaks the
fourth wall does something with x-men
characters then we'll get a whirl
building post-credit scene where it's
like holy it's cable holy is
him with characters we're gonna see in
his sequel you know idea when they would
drop a sequel if that actually ends up
coming they'll probably wait to announce
that till a little bit after the movie
comes out if it does a crazy insane
they'll probably try and fast-track it
but let me know in the comments what do
you want the Deadpool sequel to be
Deadpool vs. Wolverine or Deadpool vs.
cable and what do you think those two
post-credits scenes are in related news
it's Super Bowl Sunday there's gonna be
a whole bunch of trailers I'll be
posting stuff to social all week here
are the links for my Twitter and
Facebook be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be really fun I
know there's gonna be some Captain
America Civil War stuff I know there's
gonna be some x-men apocalypse stuff but
beyond that we'll just have to see
whatever ends up happening I will
totally do videos for it so there'll be
a whole bunch of videos coming tonight
in Monday well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my Deadpool
kills the Superbowl video and my
Deadpool playlist and you can click here
for all my Captain America's Civil War
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you